I want to start with a sincere
congratulations you're both so good in
this uh I think this movie is going to
make at least ten dollars at the box
office I think it might be a small hit
I'd say you're right yeah exactly so I
am curious though because this is this
is a movie and these are roles that I'm
sure a lot of people wanted so
ultimately how much did you both pay to
be in the movie
uh we actually can't discuss that but um
I'm I still am on the loan program
um and those payments are still going no
no uh uh yeah I mean
yeah no yes no no no yes no yeah I love
that you know what I mean though it's
like yeah no it's very very special to
be part of this it was happening yeah no
no it's I still have to pinch myself it
feels very surreal definitely does I
definitely want to talk about the
scuttlebutt song just because it's so
good and it's so catchy when you first
heard it were you like oh my God this is
gonna be it oh no the my first thought
was that how am I gonna pull this off
like and and because uh it was sent to
me with um Lynn who wrote it had done
the reference tracks so I was just like
I I just couldn't believe that I was
listening to a reference track made by
Lynn Manuel Miranda a song written by
him that I was set to perform I just
knew that it was exciting and I hoped I
did all right yeah you know uh yeah you
nailed it oh thank you I mean for real I
wouldn't just say that well maybe I
would but I'm actually being sincere but
one of the things for both of you that I
found so unique is this wasn't some like
voice over in a box recording process
like this was a way bigger performance
and can you both talk about the actual
making of the movie because I think most
people won't understand what really went
on behind the scenes yeah no it was
you're absolutely right it was really
really cool to actually be able to do it
together and I think that definitely
helped with the performance so much and
obviously getting into a character like
this there's feels you feel a lot of
pressure and you know I was quite
nervous but doing it with everyone it
just felt so fun and and real and it was
just really cool to kind of to kind of
film it that way like I'd never done
something like that before it was
awesome yeah yeah we were able to record
the scene just in a room like this
um and you could see and Rob's sitting
right there and and he can he's it's
just I never
done an animated or voice movie like
that in that way yeah one of the things
that I found striking was uh the CGI and
the underwater stuff is so beautiful to
look at and I'm convinced that he maybe
went underwater to fill I'm joking no
but for both of you what is it actually
like watching something like this for
the first time your imagination versus
seeing the finished film yeah it was
actually really cool because when we
were doing uh rehearsals we actually saw
like Styrofoam cutouts of what the sets
would look like and a lot of concept art
so it's almost like when I was watching
the film I could recognize scenes I was
like I swear I've seen that before I was
like oh yeah I've seen it from rehearsal
so it's just like following Rob's Vision
throughout
um production was really really
interesting and yeah like how like the
whole lining of the ocean like and how
they play with the colors I think they
did so so well yeah
yeah it was pretty mind-blowing because
you really have no idea you truly have
no idea and this was you know like all I
knew back then was that what they had
planned uh for like setting up and I was
just like that that sounds crazy man
like that sounds like super ambitious
and like I'm glad I'm good I'm getting
out of here I did I did the voice stuff
I'm gonna let them start start like
filming and um I I saw For the First
Time The the other day at the premiere
and I I would never be able to imagine
like the level that they brought things
to the the way the textures are in the
water how they like redid All of the the
sequences it's crazy it's a feat yeah
um I am curious the original movie do
you have a favorite scene and part two
is did you have a favorite scene in uh
the live action version
um I would have to say my favorite
original scene would be
um
I love under the sea like and um I say I
say it all the time but like the
original version is just so fun and I
love what they did with the new one
obviously making the animals look look
real in it and just looks looks like the
ocean really comes to life but in the
new one I really like the the final
sequence I really love what they did I
think that it looks like they spent like
an infinite amount of like dollars on it
it just looks so well done it looks
awesome so I love the ending sequence
with the with the final battle with
Ursula
I love the dingle hopper scene and the
original that was really that I I always
thought that scene was a bunny and in
this one I really like
um I I I'd say like under the sea it was
was so cool too yeah that was uh no
wrong answers I'm just gonna say
congrats thank you for giving me your
time and good luck with the rest of your
speed dating thank you so much